[Aplausos]
Cuando bolodimir zenlinski entró a la
sala el parlamento europeo se puso de
pie para darle una ovación al presidente
de Ucrania
[Aplausos]
con los aplausos vino una promesa de la
presidenta del parlamento
Ucrania es Europa y el futuro de su
nación está en la Unión Europea
la presidenta de la comisión europea
Úrsula Legend se hizo eco de ese
sentimiento pero convertirse en miembro
de la Unión Europea no es un proceso
fácil y por lo general Lleva años
selensky ha estado presionando por un
cronograma acelerado diciendo que su
país está luchando contra la mayor
fuerza anti-europea del mundo
queremos ser parte de la Unión Europea
Ucrania quiere ser parte de una Europa
ganadora
la escala de Bruselas sigue las visitas
de Francia y Reino Unido a principios de
semana en París pidió más armamento
pesado diciéndole al presidente francés
Emmanuel macron y al canciller alemán
olafels que el tiempo se estaba acabando
el Reino Unido hizo un llamado dramático
para los aviones de combate
me iré de aquí hoy agradeciéndoles los
poderosos aviones ingleses
el Primer Ministro británico Richie
sunak no llegó a prometer los aviones de
combate Pero dijo que nada estaba
descartado los aliados occidentales ya
han proporcionado billones de euros en
ayuda militar a Ucrania incluidos
tanques la visita Europea de zenensky se
produce en medio de advertencias de
funcionarios ucranianos de que Rusia
está planeando una gran ofensiva en el
noreste y en el sur del país que
probablemente tendrá lugar este mes
cuando la guerra se acerque a su primer
aniversario el 24 de febrero